just say he's on snl and you want to
destroy everything about snl
you can't destroy the destroyer you are
fighting
you can't destroy it's over it's over
okay it's over okay i think okay am i
wrong it could come back
i don't think it's over because i think
they can still have cultural pops
sure here's what i mean
right now yeah you have to tell people
you're on snl like if you go to out to
dinner with somebody they go what do you
do for a living you have to go i'm on
snl rock farley sandler never had to do
that what i'm what i mean is that yeah
as a as a cultural monolith yes like
it's over the yeah this the people that
are on the show media are no longer
superstars the medium is over it's
changed tv is over yeah snl you'll you
almost have to look at like um
an appearance on uh carson
so like if the actor was more famous
than carson
that was just this massive moment right
so the actor the celebrity that's going
on snl has to be more famous than snl
right if you have the guy who is in
shanghai right who's a [ __ ] great
actor fun guy sure but if people don't
actually know him enough nobody's going
to watch the episode but if you have
kanye yeah then it's the world stops
that's big you've got kardashian the
world's you've got to get people to talk
about it so now they have to worry more
about casting than they ever have that's
right and maybe it's because they're not
making their guys stars
well it's hard it's the medium right the
medium is tough
the medium i think i think i'm going to
blame it on that
there's other things but i think what do
you mean by the medium tv television
appointment television but that's not
even we never watch snl like that we
always watch the clip you also said this
when
10 000 youtubers can beat you to a
sketch that you got to wait to put out
saturday yeah i mean it's what i mean
like doing something once a week when
comedy is so quick and so yeah
like that to me is hard it's hard to do
we had to wait for snl back in the day
now you do not have difficulty yeah so
now that they're yeah now they're making
the joke last it's just also not maybe
not enough content
like to get for any one person to pop
so for any one person to get famous
maybe
they do a sketch or two a week on that
show that may not be enough now
the demands of things are so that you
have to keep feeding the beast yeah yeah
yeah okay maybe yeah that makes sense
these are all perhaps things like yeah i
don't i can't tell you no point the last
breakout stars i can think of sudaikis
and wig kristen wiig and that was
around about the time that we stopped
watching tv so much yeah i mean pete
pete yeah pete is a [ __ ] star but he
also is a star beyond snl four yeah it's
almost like things outside of snl have
made i think snl still does some very
funny stuff yeah so i don't think it's a
content issue it's just i don't think
it's i think it's the medium i i think
it's much harder to be
on tv once a week and have the relevance
that you would have
now that the world is splintered into a
million different you know internet
realities when you're hanging it at
these like global elite gatherings that
you often hang out absolutely and do you
ever bump into like a lauren michaels
i've never been in a place where he
would be i maybe i've been in places
would you check him
no i mean check him out would you walk
up and check him be like yo
like like would i fight him
if that's what that means to you yes
no i think lauren michaels is a legend i
have no
i have no problem or michael's i don't
i don't who would you check
i want to know tim dillon's checklist
you see that [ __ ] on the streets
it's on and popping
no i don't i don't really have a problem
with too many people you don't yeah i
mean they may have a problem with me
here's the thing the things i say right
people get angry at me
i don't i'm not angry they may be angry
at me i see so i'm not angry at any but
like i say the things that are true
right people may not like that right and
that may anger them
but the governor of california may be
mad at me
but that's i have no problem with him i
think he's doing a horrible job i think
he's a horrible person yeah i think he's
destroying one of the greatest states in
the union right
but if i saw him at a party i'd go how
are you ah and we'd have a nice little
talk i might go
why are you doing this
i might ask him like why are you
destroying the state
is someone paying you to do it
[Applause]